now that everyone's reviewed Shazam
already I feel like you remember Jumanji
and there was a stampede of rhinos and
when the Stampede goes by this up one
little rhinos like I probably use that
comparison before but that's what I feel
like right now I feel like the Stampede
if Shazam reviews have already happened
I'm like a shoe care so let's review
Shazam it also lets appreciate the fact
that junk lovers in this movie that's
the third DC property I can think of him
in in the second one where he has bald
kids that was cool
alright now let's review
[Music]
shows that just for a fact so Shazam is
the newest DC movie I don't even know if
the DC Cinematic Universe is still
around and I don't care to know and it
doesn't need to be around and Shazam's a
testament to that
in fact Aquaman's a testament to that -
other than one throwaway line Aquaman's
its own thang Shazam's its own thing it
looks like DC it's found its way and its
strength is not creating a cinematic
universe because Marvel did it the
strength comes from telling a compelling
story with interesting characters so the
story of Shazam revolves around a
teenager named Billy Batson he's good at
heart he just D has a bit of a chip on
his shoulder and I totally understand I
get it but then he runs across the
wizard Shazam played by John and hunter
who's like look I usually have a really
stringent and strict screening process
while doing this but I'm at a time so
now you're the hero just say my name so
every time Billy says Shazam he becomes
an adult superhero but he's still a kid
and now we have our newest superhero
movie first of all let's talk about how
good Zachary and Levi is cuz a Korean
leave I really had to hit the zone here
and Zachary Levi is perfect casting
because Zachary Levi has this like
youthful vigor about it whatever
youthful spark that keeps him spry he
hasn't lost it yet it hasn't gotten
grounded and pounded out of him from
life yet hopefully never does but he
uses that here he's perfect here because
when Billy becomes the hero Zachary Levi
you still really buy the fact that he's
a kid and that strength doesn't just
come from Zachary Levi is Zachary Levi
delivering what the script gives him and
the script and his story it makes him do
what a teenager would do if it became an
adult with superpower
I mean think of it what it's not gonna
be like how to be a hero I mean a lot of
us kids we said that but if we had
superpower what alright how did the
conversation go in junior high you tell
me yeah I'm sure it was all Noble about
stopping bad guys right not about
getting chicks sure so they put him
through that process his character arc
it's a it's a coming-of-age story he
doesn't see it as superhero he sees it
as guy with powers it's something I
really wanted to see in this movie and I
got in his movie also the chemistry
between him and one of his foster
brothers when we played Eddie from it
can think of his name right now but he
played Eddie from it and he's great in
this movie too in the chemistry between
the two works actually between Billy
Batson young and Zachary Levi Billy
Batson old I mean older not that someone
his age is held and Mark Strong plays
the villain in this movie you have Mark
Strong is not actually yes he did play
Sinestro
yeah whatever Lionel Luthor's a cameo in
this movie we've got comic book movies
have become so prominent that we're
gonna get crossover used to be an
anomaly now it's just the way Lamarque
strong as the villain he plays dr.
Zhivago
Savannah forgot the name for a second he
plays dr. sivana which he's fine he's
not the standout though and he shouldn't
be and I totally get why they had him be
the villain in this movie and not black
Adam because I feel like black Adam
would be like oh the rock the rock
completely eclipsed everybody else the
rock has that super that's the rock
superpower he's a force of nature in
Hollywood so as the rock was cast as
Black Adam Black Adam is the Nemesis of
Shazam or at least the superhero who
says Shazam his name is not Shazam so I
imagine they're saving Black Adam for
the sequel this movie is the
introduction to Billy Batson's character
this movie is about him and him learning
to be a superhero so they have a villain
who's there to push him into that
direction that's what Mark Strong does
he does it very well and does it without
eclipsing Zachary Levi or the character
Billy batts and when it's just Mark
Strong actually I really liked him as a
villain it's when he's fighting CGI
demons that's when I was like all right
I don't care about that as much I
remember the laughs I remember Billy
Batson figuring out his powers I
remember the coming-of-age element I
remember when this movie sticks in the
pocket of what I heard it was going to
be what I was hoping it was and it was
which is big meets Superman if Superman
had the powers of Raiden just there it
is when I said Raiden not Thor the
fights come secondary in this movie
they're not the point of this superhero
movie the point of this superhero movie
is Billy Batson figuring it out in a
comic book movie saturated world Shazam
comes along and it made it feel new
again it kept me laughing it was
hilarious I had great camaraderie and
then the end like to its core it's a
story about family and the family
message in this movie it hit me it got
to me a couple times is there like it's
my lip quiver what's happening what if
the DC movie start doing this to me oh
shut up in the end I will say Shazam is
worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray
yeah whatever screw it
it's too good to not do like that effect
was too good to not do poignant Shazam
is great I think you have a good time
with it watching versus Shazam have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]